hello everybody welcome back to let's
play crime fear okay
just went into a door to go to a hallway
that led to another door does that made
sense but I don't know what do I know
none of this is making sense I mean all
of it seems to be going into sir oh boy
construction say
and there is all the normal people so
warm flyer please protect me protect me
fire again I just got up
all right whatever I guess I can get it
again back into the depths of hell I
know yeah Matt damn it what the hell
I just lost health again see my crest
yeah
also it's additional that some of these
syringes come from these infected guys
so probably not a guy had a good idea to
just jam gun I remember that
what's that doing here things are just
getting weirder
it seems uneasy like in the shining the
whole set design was meant to be uneasy
get hot no too bad are you quick not
quick enough soap ugly two hits alright
I obviously do not have the padlock ah
number all over again every door is
locked
do this one thank you no no give me your
bullets is it the only thing in here
bullets in that guy huh something is
blocking the door
an enemy huh Oh Jeff welcome to the team
I'm sure your supervisor has already
gone over the basics but here's a few
things you want to know this cave is wet
cold and filled with puzzles hey watch
your step
cigarette breaks every two hours most
important the supervisor is a dick okay
remember the code to section D what is
it going to go back so you'll need to
memorize it
279 last number is covered in the ink I
can't read it
279 I
I'll just be able to try them all 279
something that says shadow
[Music]
wait seriously what's that shadow
okay something's blocking oh it's um
it's fuel it's not shadow it's fuel um
do I have a lighter or something light
it on fire
ha dirty okay
it was a number it's 279 something okay
so I can use I brute force my way
through that 279 something
[Music]
huh there we go okay got it
bingo who is down there I know that oh
no I don't like tunnels
ha ha what are you doing what are you
doing either what are you gonna give me
a gun
give me a gun reload
Oh Cup just you stay right there buddy
you stay right there thank you for
waiting patiently why don't you come
after me why I shouldn't complain about
that hello ed Sheldon I get a shotgun
sometime soon
oh please tell me yes I have a Jaime
Wow
I see that who are you who are you
George
dead dead no come on turn up turn up
dead going gone no not gone my god oh
your heads blown off
yeah oh hell yeah oh man nothing can
stop you oh I got no flashlights though
with it uh-huh that's the trade-off
unless taking duct tape a flashlight do
it baby
is that the only reason they came here
it was another pathway down
right or left dobar no one else wants to
mess with me
down this way
no open up there
from the dead
ah what is that it's not something
jumping it was my computer like
maybe I'm just freaking myself oh oh no
good stay away give me my give me the
shotgun oh yeah get it down tonight
oh all right that did something okay I'm
looking for something to light the fuel
on fire Oh file but I can't seem to
climbing those barrels of fire maybe
I don't know I don't know maybe a little
something else in that room that I
missed please this is a paper I can
light on fire oh that beat the hajikko
note here I already in here nope like a
guitar it's gotta be something shoot at
it I don't want to waste a bullet
why not worth the drive okay God must
have missed something or else if I go
back maybe maybe I'm not ready to come
this area
nope
are you ready for the baton mow down
load back up oh yes lighter lighter or a
magnifying glass or something just
something to light things on fire oh I
can't go back
darn it okay alright well that answers a
question
it must have been something past that
crawling Tunnel did I miss ya must've it
anyone else want a tangle ready to dance
oh yeah Oh
you are here very dead
oh I'm an idiot it's got a slighter
right there you kidding me wait in the
dream how could my inventory be full
what um okay I guess I'll drop the knife
whatever I got the Potala anyway
alright I got it I'm smart baby the
knife was wimpy anyway a baton is much
stronger logic but I don't want to drop
any my guns one else I'm gonna drop them
need the morphine I need need a shotgun
I need everything yeah nothing I can
drive oh okay I got be light so let's
lock it up not it on fire whoosh aah
Stan aah
don't stand in the fire you [ __ ] that
[ __ ] I'm talking to isn't me
ok I gotta cut it here thank you guys so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next part
bye bye